folks it's happening the taste buds live
stream tickets are officially on sale
where at this link right here on the
screen you can click click click click
click click click that or copy copy copy
that and you can go get yourself a
ticket for the live stream taste buds
live coming to you for the first time
ever when May 10th what time 9 p.m
Eastern Standard Time we're doing it we
got some special guests coming through
we got some special things happening
there is a lot of fun stuff going to be
going down and we've got a battle that
is more epic than anything we have ever
done on this show me again Sal the
battle the buds coming together with
some special guests some special
surprises all of it shooting straight to
you into your living room from our
studio into your home that simple folks
click that link use that link buy from
that link get your ticket now taste buds
Live May 10th 9 pm Eastern Standard Time
what's up guys come see me on the road
right now go to savocanocomedy.com for
tickets uh Bangor Maine on April 27th
the Wang theater in Boston three shows
April 28th and 29th that weekend uh two
shows are sold out so there's one show
left to get tickets then we go Maverick
Center in Utah May 5th Bellco Theater in
Denver May 6th uh let's see what else
here then we go into Texas we're going
to uh Arlington Austin at the Moody
Center and Sugarland Texas at the Smart
Financial Center May 19 20 and 21 and
just to round out the summer right now
these are the last dates I have before
the new dates are announced there's
gonna be a lot of new dates announced
soon so if you don't hear it just check
back but we got Columbus on June 2nd
Cleveland on June 3rd at the rocket
mortgage field house and the
Schottenstein Center respectively two
huge venues there the Fox Theater in
Detroit on June 4th June 15th we're in
Minneapolis uh June 16th Des Moines at
Wells Fargo Arena June 17th the T-Mobile
Center in Kansas City and the last dates
right now before we announce new who won
the ones Nashville Grand Ole Opry July
27th uh Cambridge Field House in
Indianapolis on the 28th and St Louis we
got two in St Louis on the 29th at the
stifle theater and one there's tickets
available so hope to see you on the road
Impractical Jokers every Thursday nights
at 10 brand new episodes right now on
TBS and true and please go to our store
check out our merch we're about to sell
out of this and we're about to launch a
new ones so this is the last chance to
get some merch I'll see you guys on the
road
Joe DeRosa here folks I got live dates
coming up this Thursday April 6th I'll
be in Stamford Connecticut at New York
comedy club April 20th Cleveland Ohio at
dunlap's Corner Bar two shows that night
uh you sold out the first one we added a
second and I think the second one is
almost sold out too April 21st and 22nd
Columbus Ohio at the attic Comedy Club
we're doing four shows there Baltimore
Maryland on April 28th and 29th at the
Port Comedy Club four shows uh and then
May 3rd New York New York crane theater
the I Never Promised You a Rose Garden
residency that might be the last time we
do this in New York uh so I don't know
yet but anyway come out to that show
come out to all the shows
jodarosainfo.com for all show
information and tickets and of course if
you're in New York come to Joey Rose's
open seven days a week 11 30 a.m every
day food
drinks fun it's a great time
joeyrosesnyc.com
taste buds they come into the mic
talking about the food they hate talking
about the food they like two Fool's
gonna fight but only one food can be
right taste buds hey taste buddies it's
time for t-a-s-t-e buds taste buds Joe
DeRosa has the day off you ever see the
newscasters I'm working on a bit about
this but my guest today is my dear
friend hysterical comedian Jay Larson uh
sitting in with us today a First Time
guest right first time First Time guest
long time friend uh Jay you also just
get this right off top right up top
right up top April 19th uh whether that
has come and gone yet it's right around
they were hovering around
Jay has a special brand new on YouTube
tell them about until we can get it it's
called sounds like Bruce on YouTube
backslash Jay Larson comedy check it out
it's free obviously it's free it's out
now Jason Sterling Jay tours with me and
me and the guys actually if you're gonna
be with us on on April 27 28 29 in
Bangor Maine and then three at the Wang
in Boston on April 28th and 29th Jay
will be with us Jay Massachusetts native
not Boston Proper or no just North about
15-20 minutes north Jay was with us when
we were there and all the pipes burst in
your city and so we are coming back
together uh yeah don't take it for me
watch this podcast you'll be you'll see
that you'll fall in love with Jade by
the end of it you watch that goddamn
YouTube special at the when we're when
the pipes burst we were all standing out
in the cold you were in a heated car
remember
I had pulled up in a car and I was about
to go in the back door yeah you know and
uh
I was ready I don't know what that means
we were about to start I I was looking
at my notes it was literally it was 11
minutes before the show yeah it was it
was the audience was seated yeah and uh
an alarm went off as I was pulling up
and they said don't get out you know
what and my like crazy like paranoid
thing was like did I do this
did I hang my coat on a like you know
but then the whole
that was wild said the coldest day in
125 years
but we had a uh it was formal list yeah
yeah it was good which is a crazy
because that weekend we were I forget
where we were first but you missed your
flight and then I didn't miss my flight
I made my flight then they canceled my
flight put me in another flight we were
taking off and they were like nah
plane's broken that's terrible and
you're like all right and then they put
me another flight and then I had again
they changed my connector so I could get
in on time and then they the crew didn't
show up and I I got to the arena in
Pittsburgh oh pit when uh PPG I would
have been getting off stage so I mean
yeah because Chris Johnson covered yes
and he walked off and you walked on like
dude you missed this by 20 minutes yeah
but he didn't say it that sincerely you
literally like were walking on stage
like you just missed it
and I was like yeah I I know oh I felt
better yeah
um so so so do you have a little uh well
we have so much to do today so today's
battle is for the serial lovers and we
are going to be doing Cinnamon Toast
Crunch all day which I have had for the
first time over this pandemic versus uh
something I've been having since the day
I was birthed Lucky Charms first of all
if your parents gave you Lucky Charms
like the second day out of the ground
they've liquefied it they lick yeah yeah
you can't every three hours for the
first two months and that's what they
just this is gonna be a superhuman Lucky
Charms is one of my cereals that I
almost I broke up with for a while and
pimpy were talking about this I broke up
with salmon at one point I broke up with
Reese's Peanut Butter Cups and I broke
up with uh Lucky Charms because I I ate
them too much that I was like this is I
like changed my desire for The Taste
yeah I mean well first of all can we
just go back is anyone really in a
committed relationship with salmon is
anyone like salmon me and you forever no
one you're just like I guess
yeah salmon I used to buy it at the
market I used to order it in a
restaurant and I I would like I would
love sound I used to order at a wedding
it's always one of the three no way yeah
you would take in salmon at a wedding
over the steak of the chicken sometimes
depending on my mood I won't let beef
chicken take my life never I I mean beef
is just always just like a Splurge like
we're gonna be in a wedding of course I
told Brianna yeah don't give me the
Porter House though yeah interesting
what but you're You Preach you
pre-picked that you don't show up at the
morning like damn in a salmony kind of
mood you're at your house and you're
looking at the invite oh that's not
always the case is it I don't know if
it's always the case but you like to be
that guest that lets them know ahead of
time if it's there I'm choosing gotcha
you know but I oh they have but I'd say
right now I haven't had Sam and I've
been to fine dining where my lady has
had salmon and said this is outrageous
you gotta try it and I was like I'm
sorry but I broke up with salmon sorry
and I have I can't I can't do it because
I'm afraid I'll taste it and remember
why I didn't want it anymore yeah and I
don't need to put myself through that
see that's one of the weekly meals we
make for the kids you know like when I
was married and I know she still makes
salmon I make it and my my kids would
always eat it and now my son is just
like
okay and he'll just go
to get through the salmon that's wild
because your kids are younger your kids
are what eight nine and seven nine and
seven yeah I said eight I was right in
the middle you're right there yeah
uh I would have never eaten salmon I
don't think I've eaten I ate a fish
other than a fish stick until I was like
18 same dude I mean I grew up
Massachusetts you eating Gordon's fish
sticks or every now and then my mother
would bust out a frozen swordfish I'm
like you want some swordfish are frozen
swords swordfish is a very underrated in
the freezer aisle yeah that's where you
get it really dude no one we've never
had fresh food ever all of our veggies
came out of a can yeah my my again my my
uh
the old lady yeah ball and chain I'm
trying to think of different ways to
color it but she grew up fresh food like
fat vegetables fruit like because she
grew up in a commune yeah all right I
didn't know nothing of that yeah I mean
literally I didn't eat fresh fruit like
my family was just cans that's it
Frozen's that's how we rock yeah but my
kids now everything's fresh I mean my
broccoli I buy frozen I boil it you know
what I mean I won't I won't put you on a
cross for it thank you yeah I appreciate
it but I feel the same thing like uh you
know when I uh and growing a family they
will be fresh yeah yeah growing a family
yeah that should be your next show
growing on your family I would do that
I'm very I'm very private so if I grew a
family and I advertised it people might
notice yeah
you have some derosis we have a lot to
talk about we have a lot of going to go
through dude I met see I was so stoked
to do this because I just wanted to sit
here and just Hammer DeRosa obviously I
mean we all everyone knows each other
and yeah and everybody wants to just
Crush DeRosa don't you nobody wants to
agree yeah I actually had to give the
rose that pep talk because when we
started this podcast a couple years back
he felt like oh I'm getting piled on and
they're never gonna like me and
um he would sometimes be like you know
because you're you they know you they
don't know me and I'm like but just be
yourself but then he was like himself
yeah and then he was like you know he
was you know he he can be he's an
intense personality oh my God but I I
think everyone has come to love him I
love it I don't think anyone has a
pre-judge a predisposition for us when
we start episodes anymore I feel like
they feel like we are as it was meant to
be yeah I don't know who I'm gonna go
with today say I had the better argument
today Joe was more annoying today so I
was more annoying Joe had about you know
so it's now it's now it's even but I've
known DeRosa we did Montreal conference
together in 2005. that's when I met John
way before me man ten years before yeah
and to me Joe was like the uh he's the
Paul Giamatti the comedy world you know
I mean that's who he is a perfect way to
describe and we did this this was the
last time that like Joe was out in La I
was living in L.A pre-pandemic and we do
in this show it's uh you know like Ari
show remember Ari show
um
this is not happening yeah yeah I did it
yeah okay so you know he does like just
a regular live show and the top I forget
what the topping was but like Joe was on
the show I was on the show and I
remember I had some resentment going on
because like I had asked her to do his
podcast and he's like yeah yeah I'll get
you a date and I'm like all right and so
I'm there that night and I already sees
Joe and he goes what's up are you are
you ready to do the podcast tomorrow I'm
like [__] what the rose is doing the
podcast I can't do the you know so we do
the show Joe does his story he has a
good set I do my story I have a good set
I'm getting ready to leave I'm like I'm
like all right Joker to see you but he
goes hold on we'll walk out together and
I go all right so like we go to walk out
together and then he gets stopped by
fans and they're like Joe yeah she's
talking these fans I'm like all right
I'm out of here he goes I thought we
were walking out together I go we were
now you talk yeah you're stopping yeah
so walk in the parking lot he's like I
didn't like that set I had and I go you
were great it was great and he goes nah
I don't know I wasn't that good and I'm
like I think he did fine buddy because
I've done that story three other times
on the show but for like different
categories you know it doesn't matter
you don't understand I could this is so
him yeah everything you're saying
I go I hear you man he goes yeah but
there was a manager there to see me I'm
like dude you were it was good and he
goes you know what's really bothering me
and I go away he goes that you're not
telling me like it was like Top Notch
like that it was great and I go you want
the truth or you want me to tell you it
was top-not and you go tell me the truth
I go the truth is you've done the story
three times
well you're a headliner why are you
complaining to me he's like I don't like
this about you and I go I go Joe I love
you but we don't need this conversation
he goes are you gonna do my podcast or
what I go I told you I would do your
podcast and he goes no you said and I go
no I didn't and he told me there was a
text conversation and I go I'll bet you
100 bucks right now I didn't say that
and he goes how about the 20 bucks we
just made for the show I got done we go
into the text conversation I hadn't said
it and he goes see no I hadn't said I go
see I hadn't said he goes yeah but you
said that you would do the pot I go
that's not what we bet on Joe right and
he goes he's holding the 20 and he goes
are you really gonna take this 20 from
me and I go not only am I going to take
this 20 from you but I'm going to tell
everyone that I took it when you were
your lowest point and you couldn't
believe in yourself and I never spent
that 20. I left it in my eyes what I
should have done is ripped it up I
should have taken just shredded it up oh
if he was here today and you took that
20 and ripped it up on camera and you
still have it or not you dude I had in
my closet I don't know where it is now
yeah
I love it and that's why it's like every
time I watch the clips anytime I listen
to the park I'm just like oh God like
every now and then when Joe I'm like on
Joe's side I'm like all right all right
Joey D Joey I I very much appreciate the
support you have for this podcast
because early on you were vocal in
posting about it like you kind of joined
the conversation a lot yeah and that's
really fun because sometimes like you
know people see a clip or sometimes
they'll be like oh we love the podcast
but they haven't really seen it or they
don't really love it or just to just say
it to say it but I feel like you are
invested because you we talk a lot about
the battles yeah I love it I love it I
love it and you are and I'm a food head
dude I could talk food candy and even
all day yeah yeah you're gonna open a
restaurant I know you're gonna open a uh
you had a concept I tried to buy this
Bodega I got pretty close with this guy
he may have started a big time online
reservation company because he did and
uh OT
no R yep okay and uh I like and I we
were
God damn it okay no I don't know it
doesn't matter and anyway he got the
place and I had almost opened a business
with the guy who started rezzy yeah and
now I didn't know now you only see him
when he flies overhead on his on his jet
well he was already flying overhead at
that point
we pitched him the idea he had a
different idea then he got the building
then I went to him and I'm like hey
maybe I could be involved this I was
like I'm not gonna all of a sudden open
up a restaurant you know what I mean
what am I doing and then uh
but I wanted to do this like my whole
concept was I want to do a sandwich
place that was like the the menu was
blue collar or bougie so like if you got
like a breakfast sandwich you say let me
get a breakfast sandwich I go blue
collar or bougie and blue collar would
be English muffin egg bacon cheese right
boom six bucks bougie would be like
brioche roll aioli arugula toston you
know olive oil you know and then like a
baked gruyere egg like you know Square
you know it's a great concept but you
have a limited menu and you do both
things really well yes and both and like
the bougie is like 14 bucks and blue
collar is like six I love it yeah I love
the idea chicken sandwich
I never even got to that point like I
wanted to be like there's this great
like uh little general store in in uh
heelsberg okay and it's called the Dry
Creek Country Store it's this great
little it's rail in the middle of wine
country and like all the pickers and
Growers come and they drink beer in the
front steps and they make these amazing
sandwiches that's kind of what I wanted
to like concept it feels like a million
dollars I wanted to call it Mar Vista
Bait and Tackle Shop but we wouldn't
sell any bait and tackle it was just
like the place the last place on the
dock before you hit the lake for the
weekend okay so you wouldn't call it
bougie blue that would just be on the
menu okay you know what I mean yeah no
it would be Marvin's The Bait and Tackle
it's like a little grocery store in my
neighborhood where you could pick up
things you know what I mean I get wine
get cheese
you know what it's like what are we
gonna do here I tried to get severity
brake lights you know what I mean I
tried to patent that and I couldn't do
it so what severity brake lights that
was gonna be my idea severity severity
brake lights here's your license plate
right your brake light start at the edge
of the thing and they go all the way to
the edge of the car and depending on how
hard you're pressing on the brakes they
go ding ding ding does that exist no
this is my ideas you can tell how hard
someone's breaking so if you see it Go
the web you're like oh [__] like
someone's not only that when you jam on
the brakes they go and then they go
um
you know when you're cruising down the
highway and you're like oh look
everybody's just coasting yeah and then
also
not anymore wow severity brake lights
bro and how do you get that done I you
know I went to an invention company you
know that one where the guys like
hammering the wheels yeah you don't do
that I think that those are scams well I
went there to pillaged you this was 21
years ago and they never I moved to LA
and I was like you know what I'm gonna
do not just become a comedian right I'm
gonna break into the car game
story about the guy who created like
intermittent wipers the guy who came up
with the switch for sure is like a
billionaire sure you know what I mean
that right now
he's watching this being like you know
it drinking champagne wow you were like
you were like you know you know where
the Venn diagram where uh electron
lights Automobiles and comedians meet
that's me it's a very small group safety
comedy lights yeah now you said you also
have a Serial invention I do I mean this
was another thing I wanted to come up
with again these are all patented don't
don't you dare I do think someone came
out with this idea okay sugared milk it
was just gonna be sugared milk so they I
think they do have a cereal milk you
know what I mean because all we want at
the end of the most material is who does
Milk Bar yeah you see you can get it
while you're here and test it out see if
you like it yeah sweet it's good though
yeah that was a long time ago I'm like
oh sugared milk would be such a great
way so you're saying you sell it to
drink it like like the drink of when
your cereal's done and that's yeah
that's how they do it okay you're not
saying that you you you put you use the
milk to pour into the seal okay no
unless you were doing some like unless
you were like
no pun intended a serial killer and you
were drinking like regular Cheerios
eating regular cheer you know what I
mean like who's going regular Cheerios I
am going to say that it was intended uh
uh there was it there's a debate going
on online right now there's no no uh
picture here babe
no there's a debate going on online
right now that I just heard of it I
think the answer is very clear it's very
clear
and it is how do you I guess how do you
eat your cereal right how do you prepare
yourself how do you prepare your cereal
do you
pour in the cereal and then pour in the
milk or do you pour in the milk and then
pour in the cereal
um
I I can't believe this is even a
question I can't either uh
I I can because I'm gonna throw
something at you afterwards okay that's
probably I hope it's gonna blow your
mind okay I feel like we align on a lot
of things yeah this is just like the
only time the only cereal I would ever
see this would make sense where you put
the milk in first would be grape nuts
because they sink you know what I mean
and then it's like but why are you
deciding that milk is the that cereal is
a variable you always put in how much
cereal you want and then you put the
abdominal milk based on the amount of
cereal thank you you don't pour the milk
they put the amount of cereal based on
the amount of milk that's insane it
makes no sense at all it's all going to
get to the it floats anyway it's it's
ridiculous to me to pour milk into an
empty bowl I don't I would I before
today would have thought
oh they did pull it and how many people
have 42 000. okay great so it's 93 and a
half percent below the zero first so
there are people out there six people
out of every hundred that pour milk into
a bowl and then pour their cereal why I
don't I I think just to be different
maybe like who first of all that's
passed down
it is it is that doesn't come no one no
one started that way that's something
you did in your family we're all born
pouring cereal first yeah and if that's
changed it's because of it's uh it's
nurture it's not nature so let me tell
you something that I saw my aunt Val do
when I was a kid and it it blew my mind
okay
she was making a peanut butter and jelly
sandwich for me
I like it already she had a piece of
bread out piece of bread peanut butter
right yeah then jelly on top of the
peanut butter then close the sandwich
I've seen it done but it's why you go
peanut butter here jelly here and then
you you do the whole deal I gotta be
honest with you yeah I
I probably do it as much either way you
do both and now that I'm saying it out
loud I don't know why I do that I don't
know well you know what it is I think
that maybe I'm having a much more
accurate uh
visual of the peanut butter to jelly
ratio the reality of it as opposed to
like painting on the canvas here
you know what I mean it's like one
canvas I think I'm gonna tell you
something right now Michelangelo would
do separate he would do something he
wouldn't be you know cascading it over
here that's a good question to ask you
know yeah mustard mayo when you're
making a sandwich you go mustard in one
Mayo on the other do you put them
together and mix them uh I don't do
mustard mayo but I would put them
separate but I'll tell you what I do do
is I'll tell you what happens there you
f up that that knife you up the uh bro
if you're putting it on the same one
then you're going back in the jelly with
the peanut butter and you're getting
peanut butter everyone knows the move
you peanut butter the one side you wipe
it and then you wipe on the the plain
piece yes then you go into the gel yeah
I do that too I do that too but I
wouldn't think that it would something
that would blow someone away I just
thought it was you ever do it that way
PBJ put the jelly right on the peanut
butter right now I put it um on both
sides and then always 100 yeah
I don't remember I don't know
I just throw the food on the thing and
put it inside
that's a recipe I throw the food on the
thing and put it inside me
um
it's also like some little dirty talk
right there you know what I mean like
that's how you put that's how you get
going yeah that's how you start it up
I'm trying to think if I have any any
odd food quirks
uh
how about I'll tell you what a thing
that we used to do as kids you ever do
this we would get a hot dog right out of
the fridge and just right out of the
package no no cook it's already cooked I
just I know it's already cooked a cold
hot dog I've told my kids about they're
like get out of here so here's the thing
you're right it's cooked right it's good
so it shouldn't be like a we all clutch
shop pearls though yeah because it just
sounds oh I'm gonna go one deeper I'll
go one one further yeah my mother used
to make hamburgers with ground meat and
we go over and grab the ground meat and
eat it raw
oh
yeah oh oh that no that's you could die
why are you guys in such a rush I don't
know man there's four of us we're just
getting for scraps your mother didn't
didn't of course you would like Get out
no you're not doing that you ever had
steak Tata I have okay but that's a
certain grade of steak and it's being
prepared by
a good Chef yeah you're true but your
mom but you you what what was it
seasoned no it was like I just remember
grabbing it right off the package
oh no yeah but what tastes there was no
season there was no seasoning in my
house as a kid but wait wait I will say
that hey I'm listen I'm being open here
guys I'm trying to be vulnerable I see
what Jerome is coming from
no I'm just thinking like but but like
why would you even desire that because
it's it's it's got to be terribly
tasting it's not it's raw unless she's
in ground chuck how do you get your
first of all we probably weren't even
getting ground chuck okay we're getting
whatever stock market had available on
discount you I mean when you get a
burger you go medium rare how do you get
it medium okay yeah see I Like It Raw in
the middle medium rare is too much it's
it's it's still bleeding it gets it gets
colds faster well I mean I yeah I
definitely don't want I've bitten in
before and had cold in the middle like
all right guys this is a little much but
I love a tartar I'm not gonna lie about
it I've done a tartare Carpaccio if you
will yeah I love a Carpaccio and uh you
know I sometimes I have to psych myself
up to get there yeah and sometimes I
mean it tastes good but I'm like what am
I doing right now but you know you do it
yeah yeah what's your mother's reaction
while she's cooking and you're I can't
remember she didn't cook that much let's
be honest you know what I mean she was a
single mom before your siblings would
run up and eat the rice no I just
remember I can see it on the count on
the like we had this stove that had like
a a work surface as well and like you
could get around this way to the guest
bath and I remember just like grabbing
some and eating it and I I know the
taste like I know the taste of raw
hamburger meat what's it taste like it's
it's very good
no it's it's pretty good man oh it can't
be it's I'm like hey you you you're
gonna have a host of issues after that
dude
we were when we were kids you could you
could eat dirt like there was nothing
that was ever yeah people like dirt you
know what I mean
he went through a great restaurant on
the 82nd Street
well so you know what I recently I found
out that they say raw cookie dough
actually it's dangerous to eat and I
used batter off the mixer of course uh
the you know the two the the hand mixer
Rocky's eating raw eggs what are we
talking about yeah right right so so is
it the eggs why it's dangerous no
because I eat cookies raw cookie dough I
don't need I mean I I never even
hesitated well you know what else is in
cookie dough what sugar flour both you
can eat raw eggs milk it's the eggs it's
the same with like um when I make
brownies with the kids I come home like
you want to lick the bowl like yeah who
doesn't want to lick the bowl I remember
when I yeah exactly oh God yeah yeah
it's the best so here's the thing I
remember when I saw because someone
marketed a cookie dough you can eat and
I was like what do you mean cookie dough
you can eat I just Lop off the Pillsbury
dough I just opened that yeah that thing
and I just eat it like of course like
like it's a [__] Slim Jim I just told
in my hand and chew it yeah like and I
didn't realize you could you can get you
can get let me just tell you it's saying
it's saying germs okay I am this listen
as a guy with kids and I know you're
kind of a germaphobe yeah I am I don't
give a [__] about any germs nothing
three shoot you don't care I'm not like
you you're gonna wash your hands before
I'm just like whatever okay you're gonna
get germs that's what made our
generation impenetrable yeah but knock
knock yes who's there Sal who salmonella
yeah salmonella comes from what though
do you know what it comes from chicken
cutlets chicken raw chicken raw chicken
and eggs yeah but who's I'm cleaning up
after that I'm not a I'm not an animal
you know what I mean but I'm saying like
if my kids come to the table like and
they haven't washed their hands I'm not
like oh you got a washer I'm just like
if you got germs outside or whatever you
know like my daughter wants to feel I'm
not put your hands out of your mouth no
no well then my kids don't have their
hands in their mouths you know what I
mean they're older now back when they
did you know you might be like what are
you not on your hands for yeah like my
daughter one we have squirrels in the
backyard that come over like crazy and
she's got like nut they're like they'll
come right up to her I'm like you can
feed him she goes if they bite me I'll
get rabies I go no you won't you might I
go let's look it up and it's not even
true it's not even true that you'll get
rabies really yeah look it up
you could not every squirrels are wild
squirrels are wild I know they're wild
so am I bro let's get down
you're like I'll show this [__]
scroll as well bite me [__]
Scrolls like damn I just don't sweat
he's nuts look at small roads
Chipmunks are almost never found to be
infected with rabies and have not been
known to transmit rabies to humans
you know pimpy I uh and celebrated a
birthday not that long ago and I
realized that I didn't have life
insurance and I don't know what age is
supposed to get it I don't know if my
parents ever got it but I've been
thinking about it Non-Stop and I am in
the process of getting it now I don't
know if you want to look into life
insurance as a young lad but I don't
think there's ever a time that you
shouldn't have it
right the weather's warming up the
flowers are starting to bloom it's the
perfect time to take a fresh look at
this type of stuff your financial
planning if you're meaning to get life
insurance and you've been putting it off
I think now is the time to do it so
fabric by Gerber Life will help you
protect your future no matter what
happens it'll help organize your
financial future uh you start with life
insurance okay it's a One-Stop shop for
you and your family's needs financial
needs offering high quality term life
insurance policies plus other Financial
Solutions in one easy Hub fabric was
designed by parents for parents that's
another thing if you have kids and you
don't have life insurance you have to
act immediately because you need to do
that to protect children and your family
okay
uh it was designed by parents for
parents to help you get high quality
surprisingly affordable term life
insurance policy in less than 10 minutes
uh
life insurance can get a bed rather than
being complicated but fabric makes it
easy to apply with its seamless digital
experience it's all online and it's all
on your time and if you need extra
support Fabrics team of licensed
insurance agents can answer any
questions along the way it takes less
than 10 minutes to apply to see your
quote and then personalize your quote to
fit your family's needs you could be
offered coverage instantly with no
Health exam required there's a 30-day
money-back guarantee and you can cancel
at any time protect your family today
with fabric by Gerber Life apply today
in just 10 minutes at
meetfabric.com tastebuds that's
meetfabric.com tastebuds m-e-e-t
fabric.com taste buds policies are
issued by Western Southern life
Assurance company not available in
certain States price is subject to
underwriting and health questions
guys rocket money we love them they are
on the show all the time uh and uh it is
a great product I don't know if you know
it or not we use it personally
um it's basically did you ever have
subscriptions that you may have
forgotten about and then
maybe you don't know they're out there
or maybe you know and you want to cancel
it and it is a song and dance to cancel
something you got to write an email you
got to find the link that's on the page
that's on 10 pages and you can't cancel
stuff rocket money will help you cancel
all your subscriptions uh it will not be
time consuming it will save you money
basically you you make an account and it
will tell you all your outstanding
subscriptions and if you want to cancel
something you do it with the touch of a
button all aggregated on Rocket money's
website and you hear it all the time try
this free for 30 days and then you try
you forget and they keep they keep
recurring and then maybe you're like me
you see oh 5.99 uh for this app that I
got and I'm like I gotta when I have the
chance I have to go in and cancel that
and I see the 599 charge every single
month and I just don't do it rocket
money is basically a personal finance
app that finds and cancels The Unwanted
subscriptions monitors your spending and
helps you lower your bills all in one
place it'll quickly and easily find
those for you and if you don't want to
pay anymore you just hit cancel it also
helps you manage your finances by
automatically cut categorizing your
expenses so you could track your budget
in real time get alerts all that kind of
stuff over three million people have
used it saving an average of 720 a year
stop throwing your money away cancel
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
expenses the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com tastebuds that's
rocketmoney.com tastebuds
rocketmoney.com taste buds when you have
rabies they're going crazy oh yeah you
know you don't go up to some squirrel
that's [__] tweaking how do they get
rabies I don't know who bit them who's
biting them how do you get rings
how do you get rabies but how do you get
a Raby sandwich is that what rabies is
transmitted through direct contact such
as broken skin or mucous memories in the
eyes nose and mouth with saliva and
another rabid animal
so nacho but how does that animal get
rabid
like how did they get rabid by the way I
love that we are just Googling and the
first thing comes up like we'll believe
it yeah that's what everyone whatever
they say yeah exactly yeah
it's also possible for everyone it's
from the non-biting yeah but how it has
a rabid animal get rabies
it could be bad meat really I think so
so you know what else you can get from
bet this is the one thing you can get
from raw meat tapeworm tapeworm and now
what is that a tape
that's a worm that's because it's a
couple of different types of worms right
yeah
inside your body tapeworms [__] up
tapeworm is a physical worm
that is eating your
food that you're digesting something
like that
and and a tapeworm just forms I don't
know
I never even understand how flies just
show up or worm like how do these things
like the closed trash barrel and then
all of a sudden there's like 50 Max yeah
what's going on in there so I I don't
know if I want to watch this but let's
do it I don't want to see it 32 foot
tapeworm
so it so is it not a worm is it just
like it's it's not a it is it Like A
Parasite is it actual like lit like
eating raw undercooked Meats don't see
larval or larva I get a little you know
oh the smoke fish might have larval
cysts okay
you know okay let's see what is a
tapeworm
digestive problems gluing abdominal pain
loss of appetite weight loss and upset
stomach the most visible sign is active
passing of
tapeworm segments through your ass
so you shouldn't how do you know if you
have tapeworms doctors will collect and
examine stool sample on three different
days oh that's that's even come on MRI
brain MRI of the brain or other organs
to look but is it tapeworm how do you
get rid of it next one next one down
Madison Madison taken by the mouth
but is it like is it just like it looks
like a worm but it's some type of yes
it's not an actual worm no I know it's
not like a worm like on the ground but
is it is it is it like
is it like if you extract One Is it
alive or is it just like a a bacteria
yeah yeah right I don't know to be
honest with you I don't
I'm one of these people that like I
don't need to have the answer sometimes
yeah until like like I got confronted
yeah what what's a I mean it's gross
it's disgusting yeah what's a ringworm I
mean this is how we're kicking off the
food episode you know what I mean yeah
okay I just want to make no I like a
glow worm glow worms nice glow worms are
nice yeah they're good vibe
a ringworm I don't think it's just a
rash right
yeah okay why do they call it worm
though
all right let's move on yeah okay good
so
um
we we were talking about something
earlier and I was like we're diving into
breakfast yeah stuff yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah no but all right we can get into
the bat where are we no I was gonna say
but we wrote we wrote so because we I
was like save this yeah this was from
The Breakfast issue because and it was I
think a little bit because I don't know
what your reaction was but I thought it
had something to do with like you were a
little hesitant and I was saying that
when I make breakfast for my kids at
least at least once a week I make
pancakes you know what I mean okay I'll
make breakfast sandwiches cereal for the
kids happens maybe maybe once every
three weeks maybe wow it's usually like
you're getting a stale Box by that time
I know that's if you've opened it
already I I very rarely give them cereal
wow what I'll do is like like I said
breakfast sandwiches with fruit fruit
pancakes and like sausage or bacon uh
scrambled eggs and fruit and uh
something else breakfast is a fun thing
for the like this is the most fun
communal like to make it yeah you know
everyone's it's a rise and shine type
deal it's probably home and off or maybe
you're running out of the house but
breakfast feels like the meal you make
with the kids we gotta leave for school
at like five minutes to eight I wake
them up at seven okay I get them up at 7
I'm like I'm gonna start making
breakfast they come in they sit at the
table my son usually is reading he reads
like crazy she'll draw I'll sometimes
I'll music on I make breakfast
give it to them I make their lunches
then they get dressed that's our morning
you know it's the best wow and they fall
in line oh yeah they do their reading
they're writing that's they go get ready
yep what year did they start getting
ready on their own
uh I mean they go pick out their own
clothes do all that deal now during
first and third grade I'd say maybe like
their own clothes yeah yeah so when that
happens are you like do you feel my
daughter's in first grade does full
outfits dude like Beret different hats
matching what do you think about like
she's super into my son was just like
can I get some shorts and a t-shirt
right and he likes a soft t-shirt I'm
like bro how about some you're wearing
jeans today I'll give you five bucks
yeah every once in a while switch up so
so when they start to do get independent
like that do you feel like is it like oh
this is bittersweet because I used to
like doing that with them now they're
becoming a self-sufficient or is it like
oh God thank you because now I'm getting
more minutes of my life back oh no it's
it it's it's neither I'm just like I
love doing no matter what it is because
I just love being with them right and uh
and I love that they just do it on their
own you know what I mean but my son is
like you got to be like socks and shoes
bro socks and shoes and your my
daughter's already dressed she's ready
to go I'm like then you gotta pack your
bag uh put their lunches out they gotta
pack them get them in there get your
stuff did you brush your teeth go brush
your teeth we gotta go we gotta move you
know what I mean and he's just like I
don't know where my shoes are I'm like I
do you left them in the garage you know
what I mean and my daughter's like yeah
yeah
um but so I'll when I make pancakes yeah
this is what I go heavy on the batter
you know what I mean because I don't
wanna you don't want to have not enough
because then you got to make more so I
make them up and one day I just made
them and I was like oh I got like eight
extra pancakes here chocolate chip I
laid out some tin foil stacked them
folded them and I looked at my daughter
go you want to give these pancakes to
your teacher and she's like yeah and
then I just started like I'm like oh
these guys are they're rushing to school
they got to teach these kids why not
have my daughter show up with like some
chocolate chip pancakes you know every
once in a while this blew my balls off
okay because first of all I don't lose
food
is not in play in my life yeah I get
presented with food a lot people come to
my shows they bake treats they you know
I've gotten casseroles I've gotten baked
goods and they handed me and I I don't
even I looked them right in the face and
I say thank you for your time and
efforts yeah I'm being upfront I can't
eat this I can't take this from you yeah
this is this is I need Factory sealed
stuff yeah I get it even if they don't
have ill intentions like maybe there's
not something in there that would make
me but I don't know you I don't know
your standards I don't know what this
situation is like the kitchen you cooked
it in I don't know if you wash your
hands I don't know who you are right I
can't eat your food right your homemade
food I guess sometimes people hand me
when I'm on them on stage yeah and I'll
just say pass it around yeah delete it
but they accepted these I never I never
even took any of this into consideration
I was just like oh yeah I'm just making
food and I go here and then I think this
is what normal people do and I think I'm
crazy I think first of all I definitely
think you're crazy crazy when you worked
in the bar you wouldn't share food like
if somebody brought you food when you
worked in the bar
Fame Assad you're an unknown yeah you're
just a guy sure no I would never eat
someone's homemade food not it not even
if that I knew if they're regular that I
knew you're raising their eyes there's a
difference between a regular at the bar
and someone that's in my life if he
brought me food I would eat it in a
second if you brought me food I would
eat it in a second if someone I don't
know or know peripherally brings in food
I'm gonna have a hard time man I I I it
immediately becomes unappeasing as a
matter of fact it immediately I'm like
oh
I mean I'm I go I don't like I said it's
not an issue for me I'll dive all in you
know what I mean but I've eaten off
people's plates at restaurants you know
what I mean
you mean posted you know when I used to
wait
now listen when I used to wait tables
yeah first of all I crushed I could
imagine but you have this you have a
personality that immediately delivers
one one time
one time I had a couple I feel like I
know who you are as soon as you say AMJ
I'll be a server tonight I'm talking
about the specials I get a feel for you
then all of a sudden I just I like I do
I like to I like to ingratiate throw
Banta back and forth I feel like I would
trust you right away I appreciate that
and I and I worked hard to build that
with my my guess and I remember I mean I
used to do this a lot I would let's say
I have a couple right they get the creme
brulee I come down I'm like I put it
right in the middle of the table and I
go spoon spoon and then I put a third
spoon down and then I'll never forget
they go what's that for I go that's for
me boom and I take the first bite and I
walk off and they're dying laughing
loving me and they're just like this
guy's office Rock oh my God I'm having
an actual physical reaction they loved
it I've never heard or seen anyone do
that in my life dude one time I'm
waiting tables I'm at a group of like
five you're the waiter yeah I'm the
waiter oh dude one time I'm waiting
tables I'm at a group of five and I come
over I'm like we've already been hanging
out you know this is I'm in the middle
of the night and there's a group of five
and I come over I'm like talking about
they're like we're talking about have
you ever just gone up and kissed someone
they're like what do you mean like just
walk up and just kiss them they're like
yeah I'm like no but I bet I could with
her and it was another two top that I
had and I walk over to the table and I
didn't have the guts to just go do it
and I go guys they were talking about
like going up just kissing someone I
said I should come up and kiss you and
she goes go ahead and I boom kiss her
and I look back I'm like what's up and
they were like oh my God this is a bit
we've done on the show I pay my mortgage
with that bit
um uh I gotta be honest if well it
depends who does it yeah but if you were
my waiter and you did that and you
walked away I would enjoy it well
because you're really not contaminating
anything no I was the first bite in but
they you know they went it's it it it
it's it's it's it's it deserves a tip of
the cap yeah because it's so it's so
ballsy I've never seen it done so it's
so rare that you gotta appreciate it
yeah I did I did have a bad fire one
time like two times I I went up to like
this it was a daughter with her mom and
I was like how many times did you do it
I mean I'm just talking about it as a
waiter okay and I was just like talking
to Mom and I like was like check out mom
over here and like I would just have
just being myself and the mom took it
super personal and they like reported me
and they left and
the worst was I did have this this
couple these two girls come in and it
was my first shift bartending and it was
a Monday night so you get the Monday
night shift right and I'm just talking
to him and stuff and the girl's like I'm
vibing hard with this one girl and the
other girl is like hey I'm allergic to
mushrooms and I go okay yeah and she
goes what about the pepperoni calzone
I'm like no mushrooms she goes you sure
I go 100 percent
put it in still vibing we're all getting
along they get it you get the calzone
she starts eating it and she puts it
down she's like oh my God and I go with
somebody she goes there's mushrooms in
this I go there can't be and they made
it wrong it was not on me and they're
like she's like I need to go right now I
have to go to the hospital I'm like oh
my God I'm so sorry and I followed him
out on the way out I asked her friend
out I'm like you think I could get your
number and she's just like they called
the restaurant the next day and they're
like yeah this guy tried to like pick up
my friend when she was awesome oh my god
did you get the number no I didn't get
the number but again the sack to ask
after she was poisoned I was the friend
a friend wasn't poisoned okay you know I
mean she just had to take her you know
I'm not allergic to anything
you know she had a poison friend she was
dying I I would I would I would she was
definitely would have respected that too
now did you say right there I they made
it wrong like it was oh yeah you were
cleared yes they weren't calling because
no they were you've got the mushrooms
they were calling because they and they
were friends with the owner so that's
like you know that no oh wow so what
happened he took me he called me to his
office it was across the street and he
called me and he's like you know Jay
last night uh you know these girls and I
go oh yeah yeah I go I know the mushroom
thing goes you know they're friends and
like they told me you asked her friend
out and I go well we were kind of vibing
you know what I mean he's like Jay the
girl could have died and I go yeah I
didn't know it was that serious
so he's like all right I'm gonna I'll
keep you on Monday nights but like just
know you're on a short leash and I'm
like I appreciate it are you a
bartending yeah oh that's yeah you can
ask people out of your apartment no I
know it comes with the territory it
comes with it comes crazy
um yeah wait so the teacher how did they
receive the pancakes did they think how
I thought did they just take a so my
daughter came home and I go hey what did
they think about the pancake she's like
they loved it you guys and then like
that day forward every day I was making
pancakes my daughter like don't forget
to make some for my teachers so I think
I've done it a total of nine times nine
times nine times Ferris Bueller bro oh
my God I have it right here all day all
day oh thank you so much for that I mean
do you ever edit in these
yeah like pull things out oh so yeah
okay cool I've been doing punch up for
myself I'm gonna tell you something okay
you'd have to pull yeah yeah I just did
it this past this week oh last week I
wrote punch up on the third draft are
you happy with what you did yeah I mean
he's happy too and like he's it's really
cool like how does how does like
punching up for a script work I go
through and and I mean I've done it but
what do you need to take out of here
just so just okay because you could just
say you punch up scripts and that could
be fine yeah I just want to know what
you need out yeah but punch up I've done
punch-up on movies where it's like hey
take a look at this First Act and they
give me the pages and like is this story
tracking then I'll get ones for scenes
we need a joke here and like I'll go
through and do a joke punch there'll be
ones who like go through it and just
punch up one certain character you know
stuff like interesting all different
ways do they take it as you being
critical to the or the writer's not
involved oh this is the writer oh
interesting and then I did one there was
this movie on uh Hulu it came out a
couple years ago they just did a second
one it's called the binge you I don't
know if you saw it but it's pretty funny
Vince Vaughn was in it anyway I did
punch up on that and I would just like
it was just like give us as many jokes
you can then it was like check this do
this and I would just give like you know
stuff like that how do you get your name
in the ring for that how do you throw
your hat in the ring I wrote a script
with the guy who produced that movie and
then I was just hitting him up like hey
man I would love to work and he's like
you wanna do any punch-up work and I was
like yeah and then I punch up two other
movies that he was working on she liked
punching stuff up because I do it on the
show all the time yeah but can you
change the plot what do you okay if
they're having a problem with the plot
yeah yeah yeah you know interesting for
me punch-ups is always just like jokes
you know like but uh it's fun I I
because I like going in because it gives
you a starting point you know like and I
like tooling around and making something
work it's like you know like Yeah by
getting the job right right also you
know sometimes when you get to Studio
level punch up the money is crazy
ridiculous crazy and if you're an onset
punch-up guy like you're just on set
every day there to come up with jokes
yeah
Stupid Money the heat is on but you're
there yeah I had friends that were
making 25 000 a week or not on a
punch-up job they're not common no they
are they are common yeah okay a week a
week and there's four of them
holy [__] dude yeah didn't Carrie Fisher
famously Dr Scripps a lot I don't know
maybe I think she was like a Hollywood
script doctor like for show interesting
I heard my friends had a movie they they
needed a punch-up they did a table read
flew this guy in who's a writer he came
in they did a table read everyone left
except the producers the director and
this guy and he goes they want it was a
pass on the script for more heart they
needed more heart
the guy goes page 18 they're like yeah
go three quarter down like you could put
hard in here and then he just did that
through the whole script and then he
left they paid him 125 000 oh my God
didn't even say what the heart would be
or what you could add just where you
could put the heart so a lot of times
when I've done passes I'll be like hey
man I feel like you could go with some
heart here like what's the backstory
between them where did they meet and
he's like I don't know I'm like well why
don't we create that backstory and then
like we would drop it in and stuff like
that but so crazy people go to school
and go into debt to know a trade yeah
the guy just know his heart that's crazy
yeah yeah and to not say what well
that's so annoying that was the level
this guy was at like he's like put art
here and they Lisa it's like what the
[__] we put there well some of those
guys might say I want writing credit if
I'm going to give you like actual stuff
right I want writing credit right anyway
um so back to the pancakes so then I got
to the next then I got to a level where
I was like making breakfast sandwiches
for the kids and I'm like I'm just gonna
make two extra breakfast sandwiches and
I'm gonna cut them in half so it'll be
four total because it's not just my
daughter's teacher she's in first grade
and the other first grade teacher Mr O
she the her her teacher will go over to
Mr O and be like hey River's dad made
pancakes she wants something he's like
yeah so words getting out back to school
night last week I never met Mr O and so
River my daughter was like hey you want
to come over Mr Oster and I go yeah so I
want to go hey Mr O I'm J I'm River's
dad he goes you're the pancake guy and
I'm like oh thanks for sending those in
oh so you don't think that she hands
them to them and they walk into the
teacher's lounge and put them in the
pail I don't know because and then and
then oh thank you they could but I never
got complaints and even if they were
complaining I just didn't care well let
me ask you this then yeah how's he
supposed to eat that just like vanilla
wafer it's dry and Cold Mill away two
things the pancake shouldn't no dude
they're still warm when they get to
school buddy so a warm
dry
pancake not dry don't don't say they're
dry well okay so they're moist they're
moist yeah okay and let's be honest
you're a school you're a school teacher
right yeah you got to get up you're
teaching first grade dude you teach them
first grade you think you're getting a
hearty breakfast or getting no you get
into school with whatever you got and
all of a sudden someone hands you a
chocolate chip warm pancake that you can
just pop in your mouth real quick before
you got a little Boost energy I get it
around 10 30. you know yeah yeah yeah
yeah absolutely yeah no but I would so
then he eats the the chocolate chip
pancake in front of the class I don't
know their schedule I'm not interviewing
them I'm fascinated that he I wonder if
he opens the tinfoil and like holds it
like he's holding a cookie and then
teaches them phonics while he's chewing
on it
you know what I mean yeah yeah I will
say we added back to school night and me
and my ex were there we go together you
know we have a really good relationship
and we're sitting there and the my
daughter's teacher goes hey thanks for
like bringing those pancakes and I go
yeah of course and my ex is like I will
not be making
because she's more aligned with you this
would be like no no no right in terms
like not it's not like a question for
wanting to do it I think it would be
like I wouldn't put someone in the
position where they would need to eat my
pain sure but I'd say at its core it's a
little slice of Americana and I love it
that's what I'm saying yeah I think
there's something nice about it so
speaking on something nice about it
Lucky Charms have marshmallows they sure
do you know so I mean if you want to
call them marshmallows they're
dehydrated so I mean you forgot the
chant the rose is gonna be upset oh my
God all right all right so basically as
an another to Rosa made up chance yeah
so I've seen it before but I'm not like
time for uh TST buds is how we started
and then we go and then when it's time
to get into the battle I say it's time
to beat eight is this what I say
b-a-t-t-l-e butts now with the battle
buds BattleBots because we're shifting
gears yeah so we do that and then we
usually chant no matter what happens I
love you or it's time to get salty three
times and then we either insult each
other uh just to get our engines driving
or like or or I guess no matter what
happens I love you is is enough yeah we
no matter what happens that love you
came about because he was taking the
stress from this argument's home from
the food arguments sounds very Joe
exactly I actually would love for him to
compliment you we should enforce that on
so no matter how I love you know and
then you compliment then you have to
compliment yeah yeah
yeah we never did that okay so we have
two Powerhouse cereals well no matter
what I do this is why it was oh why I
wanted Joe here because it's so easy to
go where I do I do a line a lot with
your tastes you know what I mean yeah
and um
so I do love it no matter what I'm gonna
love you at the end and I'm not gonna
take any of this home right exactly and
I also know my cereals better I mean
it's just that simple bro
you know what I mean I'll tell you what
else is not taking home pancakes because
you're giving them out to everybody who
[__] take them uh so so so so all
good so we have two Powerhouse cereals
now I had not tasted Cinnamon Toast
Crunch until the pandemic and I know
I've heard it's lore I've heard it's
Legend how did you get that long in life
that you didn't have cinnamon toast I'll
tell you you know I don't cinnamon might
have thrown me because I'm thinking of
like are you gonna try and tell me
you're not a cinnamon fan no I do like
cinnamon but here I'm thinking cinnamon
like big red cinnamon in my cereal you
know what I'm saying
much Bakery cinnamon yeah yeah even
though it's based on Bakery cinnamon
cinnamon toast crunch and it's also like
there's not an item in the baked goods
world where cinnamon isn't a star
cinnamon roll uh coffee cake coffee cake
bro okay morning bun I mean anything you
put cinnamon in your pancakes you put it
in batter anything Cinnamon's on is a
win it is it is and I I don't know why
straight up it's not straight up you
ever pounded cinnamon I never I have I
never did I threw up yeah there's a bar
in Boston and like they play games
behind the house at the end of the night
drinking games and one of the losers you
have to pound cinnamon and I had to do
it and it was dangerous I don't know I
think you should die yeah
the cinnamon challenge is a viral
internet food challenge participants
film themselves eating a spoonful of
ground cinnamon under 60 seconds without
drinking anything with the video being
uploaded to the internet as evidence
challenge is difficult carry substantial
health risks because the cinnamon coats
and dries the mouth and throat resulting
in coughing gagging vomiting and
inhalation of cinnamon yeah we were
drinking gin this night too
nobody can exchange this is crazy unless
it's in a cocktail or yeah it was always
like the bougiest cocktail Restaurant in
Boston that's it then because I used to
have old guys coming in just a little
gin on the Rocks yeah that's now I know
the guy too yes Niels Niels yeah yeah no
Niels was the guy that in my bar that
used to come in oh really Niels he was
oh you retired UCLA come in and he'd
have gin martinis three yeah like it's
nothing yeah it tastes like goddamn
turpentine or whatever it tastes like
something yeah I don't know what it
tastes like did you have that red face I
feel like gin gives you he didn't he was
a great guy he would bike there
sometimes like his daughter had to come
get him and then during yeah and then
after and then when they were looking
for Osama Bin Laden don't have to come
get him anyway when they look for Osama
Bin Laden he would bring in maps and
like he and his buddies who might be
right here retired UCLA Professor
drinking gin martinis that was
delusional I'm telling you
so so I think in my head uh like when I
was young
dude forever ago but I think I think
when I was not of the age to buy and
control what cereals were being
purchased 84. 84 so yeah I'm eight years
old when it comes out my it wasn't in my
mom's rotation and so what was we had
we had we had all the plain ones right
we had the Cheerios plain Corn Flakes
plain and Rice Krispies plane yeah we
did sometimes we did Raisin Bran and
then if we [__] with sugar we could
get what we wanted but it was like it
was either Lucky Charms Froot Loops
Frosted Flakes okay I'm in on everything
so Captain Crunch berries and maybe
Fruity Pebbles those are the fives I
really like that would that was sugary
I'm gonna say this I think when Cinnamon
Toast Crunch came out
it disrupted the serial category the
same way Cool Ranch Doritos did really I
do and I think they think the whole
cinnamon space was I think people were
just like what the [__] why have you
know like when you see a comedian do a
joke and you're like how [__] I was like
yeah that's what Cinnamon Toast Crunch
right in the same way Cool Ranch Doritos
when they came into the game people were
like what the [__] is this yeah they
were a Serial disrupter yeah yeah big
time so I never had it and then after I
never had it I got to tell you like in
at a certain age it was never like
serial curious yeah you know I stayed
with my 10 Staples whatever it was
depending on my mood yeah but I would
never I would never be like you know I
never this let me try it yeah you know
unless I had it incidentally like a
honeycomb I would never buy that I would
have it incidentally Greg Hansen I had a
Craig Hanson's house yeah and I was just
like nah I'm good on this but you never
got the variety pack when they started
doing the little minis and then Cinnamon
Toast Crunch was in there I can't
remember when I got introduced to it but
I never did it so so for me I I lived a
childhood without it now Lucky Charms
when I was growing up I think was the
the BDS the big penis swinging I think
it was yeah uh Lucky Charms I think had
every kid on lockdown well I think Lucky
Charms that was the one where you would
go to a kid's house and he had Lucky
Charms and you were like oh [__] that's
also the kid who had like a fruit
roll-up at lunch at school yeah man your
[__] parents are killing it yeah I
never you know what I mean yeah I never
got like individual bag of chips in my
lunch mine was like a plastic bag and
you took a handful out yeah and you know
Ziploc [__] yeah yeah my mom would wrap
three cookies in tin foil yeah exactly
allowed to have three yeah I mean we had
pickles wrapped in in Tennessee did you
go to school pickles oh yeah no late in
life pickles for me yeah cell surf
pickles mustard all late in life yeah
mustards are later in late late in the
game no no kids
yeah yeah but my mom so someone told me
a trick and kids if you're watching I
might have said this before but one time
there's a friend family friend the house
and my mom was like you had you know
three only three guys were at the table
and he goes you know what to do right I
said right he goes you don't put the
three in front of you he goes you take
one at a time she'll never know which
one you're what the number is that
you're reaching for
in that sitting I ate a sleeve of Oreos
and that's sitting yeah and uh the
reason that I might die early is because
of that man yeah
charms had a sweepstakes back in the day
where the winner would win a live rabbit
no [__] way no no wonder why they got
so many kids involved yeah I mean a live
rabbit the parents were pissed well okay
so let's let's let's break this down
Lucky Charms has everything that's gonna
appeal to a kid and and actually to this
day
Lucky Charms I think for me at least was
the first cereal to be like we're
putting a dehydrated marshmallows and
other cereals all followed suit the so
many cereals that don't even deserve who
came in later with the marshmallows oh a
lot a lot of cereals that shouldn't even
here just like yeah we'll throw
marshmallows and you'd be like what that
doesn't belong here yeah it doesn't
belong yeah and I'll tell you
the marshmallows the Marshalls they
because they were dehydrated
depending on the the stage that you ate
the marshmallow it was a different taste
and texture experience right you get
them off the top there's a snap there's
a crunch there's a dryness with with the
milk right you get them in between you
got a slick coating on the outside which
was nice on the tongue but you would
bite through and still in the center you
might get a snap you wait till the very
end and they're soggy but not in a bad
way I also like the way they dyed the
milk I also love the different shapes
and colors but then they were they
didn't just stop there they were
Innovative they kept going
when I was a kid they didn't have purple
horseshoes I lived through purple horses
it was green clovers they blue stars and
yellow diamonds and that was it just
like tricks only had three colors yeah
it was orange red it was my yellow
orange red and maybe primary colors
primary colors yeah
right and so that's one thing I also
like that you can choose how you want to
eat Lucky Charms right like some some
people will eat all the marshmallows
right away that's not what I do you
either eat you could eat it all the
marshmallows you could eat it uh
distribute it in the spoon but when
you're really like kind of into it you
know what you do you eat everything but
the marshmallows yeah and I think they
might have done oops all marshmallows at
one point and that was definitely like
diabetes I think you can buy them
separate I think you can buy the
mushroom the uh really the marshmallows
separate really I think you can what do
you mean oh so they still do that it's
Lucky Charms only marshmallows listen to
me
let me tell you something about Lucky
Charms okay yeah they're magically
delicious but what else
I I will I want to give you I just want
to give like a a nod for what I do like
about them because I think they're maybe
the only cereal that if you ate dry it's
still good it's a snack it's it's a
snack it is and if you pull the
marshmallows out and just had it look at
that oh my God two and a half pounds to
thirty dollars
keep one in the office if you took the
marshmallows out and you ate that cereal
it's still a good cereal but I would
still would I'm not listen I'm gonna I'm
gonna say I like Lucky Charms it's gonna
it's gonna it's probably gonna fall in
my top five okay okay Cinnamon Toast
Crunch over it yeah but I will say this
too I'm not I don't like them I don't
really like marshmallows we talked
earlier about how Peeps are terrible
Peeps are gross I'm overrated I don't
mind it melted on a small but other than
that I realized but I like a dehydrated
marshmallow yeah go figure yeah I don't
know it's it's like they're they're just
taking it out I mean do you like
dehydrated fruit it depends on my day
mood and the fruit
I will ask you this
do you have a mascot
because I thought you had Bakers and
toast crunch definitely we just pulled
up a thing and it was there was no there
was no mascot on that let me tell you
something right now Sal if you need a
mascot to sell you on the food I don't
need it you think a Keebler elve is what
turned me you know what I mean no I
don't I don't need a mascot what's the
what's the you know the the Bruins are
the best hockey team in the NHL right
now they're gonna set the all-time
record for wins you think there's some
you think they have a Bayer that maybe
goes around no one gives a [__] about
the bear and look at this guy well who I
don't know hold on that guy first of all
it was three Bakers and a knock knock
who's there Rice Krispies cold and you
got a nice fat lawsuit on you okay
because that's [__] by the same
company all these companies are better
with each other now three of them are
gone now it's just one old kooky looking
guy it says Chef Wendell
Chef what Wendell what's his name
Wendell who who is this none of it
matters can we go to the Wiki page and
go to the mascot I disagree I think that
when you eat a cereal I think that it's
the total package packaging and cereal
matters I believe uh was there a prize
inside what game's on the back uh you
know I like I like the packaging
especially as a kid so I do think it
adds to it doesn't experience to the
experience
I I mean lucky you think I've given out
that
[Music]
shot labor
listen they came out in the 80s you know
[Music]
which by the way I have another thing to
ask what I never heard of cinnamon toast
in my life oh really folks want to take
a moment to talk to you about one of our
sponsors Factor this spring you're gonna
need nutritious convenient meals to
energize you for warmer active days and
keep you on track reaching your goals
doing what you want to do living your
best life and guess what that's where
Factor America's number one ready to eat
meal kit can help you out they're going
to help you fuel up fast with ready to
eat meals delivered straight to your
door you'll save time you'll eat well
and you'll tackle everything on that
to-do list it's that simple
too busy to cook with the spring well
with Factor you can skip the trip to the
grocery store you can skip the chopping
and the prepping and the cleaning up and
all that stuff factors fresh never
frozen meals already in just two minutes
two minutes I've eaten these things
they're delicious they're uh uh coming
in many different options too by the way
you can get Aikido you can get calories
smart you can get vegan you can get
veggie protein plus whatever you want I
like this program I like this company I
like how this works they send you the
meals after you pick what you want that
fits within your dietary preference and
you got it right there in the fridge you
pop it in the microwave two minutes
you're eating and that's all there is to
it you want to cut back on that takeout
I know I do get Factor instead not only
is factor factor cheaper than takeout
the meals are ready faster than
restaurant delivery okay anyway you get
where I'm going with this head to
factormeals.com tastebuds50 and use code
taste plus five zero to get 50 off your
first box can't beat that that's code
taste buds five zero at factormeals.com
taste buds five zero to get 50 off your
first box
folks I want to talk to you about Shady
Rays what's worse than buying a pair of
expensive sunglasses and then losing
them right after you get them I have
done that a zillion is it a zillion it
might be a zillion times I have lost
more sunglasses than I have umbrellas at
this point in my life but more than I've
I've lost more sunglasses than I've lost
lighters it drives me crazy I've also
broken sunglasses I just I can't stand
it but here's the deal Shady Rays help
me fix this problem Shady Rays makes
high quality sunglasses that are not
just as good or in my opinion better
than the expensive ones uh but you're
getting them for a fraction of the price
that's all there is to it Shady raids
are durable they're built to tackle all
of life's little Outdoor Adventures or
big Outdoor Adventures the styles are
Timeless they're on point and they look
good I look good in a shady Ray
how many things can you use the word
Shady with and say they make you look
good well I don't know many but I do
know one Shady Rays anyway they're
strong also too so here's the thing you
don't got to worry about breaking these
things ever all right every pair oh by
the way you don't have to worry about
losing them either because every pair of
shady Rays is backed by their industry
leading lost and broken Replacements
program you break or lose your pair the
second you take them out of the box
they'll send you a replacement pair no
questions asked
that's it Shady Rays isn't happy unless
you're happy that's why they give you 30
days too to try them out and if you
don't like them you can exchange them or
return them for free with every order
Shady Ray's IMPACT program works with
non-profits Worldwide to make an impact
on the lives of children and young
adults like building playsets for
Pediatric cancer patients or creating
Adventures for young adults with cancer
and Ms
Shady Rays is a good company man they're
doing some really really good stuff so
anyway here's what I want you to do
what's better than getting one pair
of shady rays and not worrying about if
you break or lose them getting to
getting to go to shadyraise.com taste
buds and use code taste buds for a
limited time when you buy one pair of
shady Rays you'll get a second pair for
free that's
s-h-a-d-y-r-a-y-s.com slash taste buds
and then you use code taste buds to get
your second pair of shady Rays free
Shady rays.com tastebuds promo code
taste buds not it's not cinnamon toast
you get a piece of toast you heat it you
butter it so it builds up little puddles
of butter then if you're like me a Super
Dad yeah you have a jar which I do have
in my cabinet that's mixed cinnamon and
sugar together with a little spoon and
then you go over and you go across the
bread do you know how unbelievable that
is in the morning before you head out
delicious Health Wise I don't know
everything in Balance buddy they're
getting scrambled eggs fresh fruit and
then a piece of Cinnamon Toast But but
so is that a thing that they took from
they just said it no but did they take
with cinnamon toast a thing and then
they made into a cereal or was like they
did this and people like oh cinnamon
toast makes sense I think I mean I don't
know when it originated but I've never
heard of it my whole life we would do
that you've heard of sugar mixed
but is it because of this no I remember
the shrimp tails I remember this in this
in there they found shrimp and uh Mentos
crunch I don't remember that at all it
was like two years ago well two years
ago it didn't affect either way I'd you
know what I'd still eat that box no
throw the stuff
one time
I swear to God my mom found a San
Francisco trees San Francisco Nails
Nails of a rat who identical or mild
Mouse whatever Nails animal nails how do
you know they were close oh you you know
you just look at me like that's a
[__] nail oh my God two snail
whatever like it was flesh of a
non-human in the rice ceroni and I
remember like she saved it because we
were like blown away but I don't know
what I don't know what if we took any
legal action did you see the rat inside
of food that was served at a restaurant
in Manhattan no yeah inside the food in
the food yeah what do you mean a cooked
rat
oh you know we all right a rat went into
a soup they scooped it out didn't notice
they served it look at it it looks good
you're kidding me
oh yeah what well what's the rest of the
items in there and what what restaurant
is it yeah what restaurant just closed
for Good
yeah that's tough
a black dead black rat floating in a
soup
in Manhattan we ordered Sogo Sogo
I don't want to butcher it I already
have Korean beef soup oh that's tough
what would you do so that's actually
traumatic I think if if they put a
spoonful of the broth in their mouth
already that's that's full yeah look how
much it's been eaten in that
yeah that's trauma right there I mean
listen if you haven't seen rat tattoo we
had to do great film yeah
that's the only thing that could kind of
soften the blow for them is they get
Ratatouille as the mascot and like what
he wants to do they cooked it I mean
this is a you you liked him there's a
sequel on him make uh so so so so I will
say this imagine that that rat yeah
imagine like he never knew what his fate
was he's gonna drown in soup not even in
water yeah he drowned in stock in soup
I can't believe this is happening to me
right now
I'm drowning in boiling soup yeah I
never happened to me I wonder what he
did things that could kill him yeah
soup I mean he finally got to the
promised land
that's something else it said that's it
um so back to the cinnamon toast yeah so
now they what did they fire the three
Bakers and they just hired the captain
seriously on the mascot is is your angle
he retired to the back of the he's just
so then you have no mascot anymore you
know what happened they listen oh sorry
cinnamon Emoji was the mascot now that's
what I read what's a cinnamon Emoji
every now and then you gotta get people
you know you're trying to break into the
the cereal game yeah you know so you got
these three Bakers or whatever trying to
get people know first of all what other
cereal has
taking over the markets as hardcore as
these guys did and then they were just
like all right we don't need a mask
anymore we survive on taste you know I
mean like everyone knows so that's it
now now they're going back to three
emojis I will say I wish they look more
like toast right they just look like
your standard Square flake
you understand
my my my my my blue diamonds yellow or
purple Horseshoes and yeah you know that
they look like that I have a diamond I
have a balloon right I have a ring you
know I have it it looks like it yeah you
ever see them they do the waffle Chris
or the cookie crust and it looks like
cookies it looks like waffles right but
this is doesn't matter because it's just
delicious okay is there a better cereal
milk than Cinnamon Toast Crunch there is
no better is that right what milk is
gonna taste better Fruit Loops no no no
fruit loops just kind of taste like a a
generic strawberry milk out uh Frosted
Flakes no Frosted Flakes you're gonna
have to weave through all the uh moldy
uh
you know what I mean flakes all those
soggy flakes dude Frosted Flakes you got
about eight seconds to enjoy a bite of
that cereal I almost put full disclosure
I almost put Frosted Flakes up against
them and I told you it was more to bite
more to chew on no pun with Lucky Charms
yeah but for us the flakes I love eating
them in all those stages as well no I
love that at the end of a sopping asapi
sappy uh Frosty flake you do yeah it's
it's the stages I eat it in different
stages yeah yeah I like or you know you
pour a little more in and you you split
the diff I I see that's what I'm talking
about yeah yeah know your game you know
what I mean how was your it's crunching
the name yeah how do you sustain in milk
it it holds up pretty strong yeah I will
say now you don't want to just leave it
and then go do something else and come
back to it what about it's soggy is no
good it no it's still delicious it's an
amazing taste okay The Taste is
everything it's the cinnamon it's the
sugar it's sweet it's everything you
want in a breakfast cereal if you don't
want sugar in your cereal then just get
out of town you're in the wrong game
here there's a Cinnamon Toast Crunch
spread you see that yeah I see it you
ever try that no I haven't what could
that be but listen I'm not saying a
cereal needs to be great because it
transfers over into other categories you
know what I mean okay if I'm gonna do a
spread I'm gonna go with a Nutella you
know what I'm saying a lot of charms
come out
I just want to know who who played to
the flag first to Lucky Charms came out
in 1964.
well there you have it this is 1964.
that's something else it's been around a
long time now I think looking on the
Zeitgeist I think Lucky Charms is
impressive too Lucky Charms ice cream
I take Lucky Charms you know I'll tell
you not to deviate really quick I would
say I think Lucky Charms is impressive
to a child now imagine imagine 65 years
ago these kids must have been ripping
their own genitals off they don't know
what to do with themselves you know they
must have been like oh my God it's the
idea of some kid ripping his nuts
running outside with a bloody crotch
just being like I couldn't take the
taste yeah that that must have I mean
1964. the first of all the 1964 lucky
looks he actually looks like a character
from like uh like uh like the Rudolph
yeah yeah uh what do you call it and
look he's feeding it to animals the guys
1973 Lucky Charms lucky he looks
demented he looks cracked out 75 looks
the only deviation they've ever had 75
is a different person yeah I don't know
it looks like Fred Flintstone look
they're trying to sell eight essential
vitamins
that's crazy that they did that I
actually read that uh Lucky Charms was
banned in New York for a couple years
until they said the vitamins line then
it was allowed back in New York state
really look at the 2010 looking wait
what year was that uh here it's over
here look at 2010 lucky he looks like a
complete sociopath yeah they banned it
looks like a murderer
60s oh in the 60s
Children characters they're all
unhealthy all that's why everything is a
you gotta like fortify with yeah wow
that's good you gotta have a little
moderation you know what I mean and a
little hack that like my ex taught me
when my kids come out to breakfast now I
just put the fruit out so when they come
out the fruit is there so it's like you
know they're gonna get some healthy
sugars in because they're gonna throw
that in their mouth no matter what and
same at dinner time you just put out
some veggies on the table ahead of time
so when they're looking for they just
grab some carrots or tomatoes good idea
so they're just eating those things
because you want them getting you know
balanced you want balance and everything
you don't want them thinking you can't
have sugar let them have sugar but
bounce it out with the veggies and the
fruits and Cinnamon Toast Crunch ever
deviated from the original flavor in any
way shape or form listen I didn't go and
do like a full study on this I don't
think so I think it's been the same as
it's always been it's never changed
so that's a caramel cinnamon toast
crunch
they're all going to try something
different Sal right oh here you go
there's your answer okay cinegram Toast
Crunch now I love a graham cracker dolce
de leche Toast Crunch cinnamon crunch
churros I bet those are awesome Cinnamon
Toast Crunch pancake mix pancake mix
cake mix I think that's gonna be too
much for me Jesus Christ chocolate Toast
Crunch now that's French Cinnamon Toast
Crunch coffee cake wow oatmeal oh did
boy did they ever expand this excuse oh
look at this Cinnamon Toast Crunch
cinnamon they did it they did it
coffee creamer
holy holy the whole coffee creamer Toast
Crunch all right somebody getting a
meeting now and cinnamon Cena Fuego hot
cinnamon cereal that's a pouch reusable
pouch
also bugles bugles cinnamon toast come
on man oh yeah those are coated that's
good I mean God damn it a lot of
crossovers they did a lot to Brand out
but I mean that scares me that scares me
because you you really threw out a wide
net there is that that's it in the
battle I don't know if Lucky Charms has
that many variations no I think Lucky
Charms does but they're all gonna try
this [__] you know what I mean they're
all gonna try doing this what else do
they get linked up with they're under
the same General Mills dude oh they're
both on the jam yeah I mean look at you
there's your Swiss Miss Lucky Charms
right there oatmeal same thing the lucky
charm bar you know and then what's this
jet jet puff Lucky Charms magically
delicious marshmallow cake mix cupcake
mix jet puffed it's the opposite of the
dehydration I wonder what those taste
like all right so we're out there we're
out there they out there I'm just saying
pound for pound if I'm gonna get a syrup
if I'm gonna get cereal
I'm going Cinnamon Toast Crunch that's
what I will go
that will be my number one number one
that's my number one draft if I'm
drafting cereals I'm gonna go one I'm
not saying Lucky Charms isn't going to
be up there there would definitely be a
starter on my team too but they'll be in
the top five maybe top eight who lucky
they're not your one no Captain Crunch
batteries is gotcha yeah all right so I
wouldn't even have Captain Crunch
berries in my top
15. you know that's crazy nope that's
widely known I wouldn't even that's one
of the Pinnacles of cereal when they
threw the berries in with one of Zero's
brightest moments yes don't even get me
started on the oopsol berries those are
the top 10 of sales in sales okay oh but
sales is nothing that should be raising
Brands eight you know what I mean
Special K is seven I don't know who
still gets Special K
sweeties how are they still in business
who eats where's Wheaties on this list
Cheerios Honey Nut Cheerios Frosted
Flakes Cinnamon Toast Crunch Lucky
Charms so we got ourselves a battle
because how much those frozen fruit
loops so I everything I I mess with
everything on there except Cocoa Puffs
and Special K which I could eat
specialty look at this down here wait
it's worth noting that the popular
specific cereals can vary depending on
factors such as region age group and
cultural backgrounds right like I I I
don't ever think this is something
that's important is like how much
because the some of the greatest bands
of all time are not going to be like
wildly popular some of the best
comedians aren't gonna be you have to
you have to be you have to be Bland or
you have to hit average you have to hit
like to be hugely successful right you
know I understand that now every now and
then things are going to collide they're
going to be like smart funny
entertaining deep and hit a white like
Seinfeld was very specific you know what
I mean and it was very broad right okay
so that's what you're saying
cinnamon toast crunches what I'm saying
is sales don't matter to me okay and
look you know I just as far as I'm
concerned it's the best indication
though of how how many how many fans are
of the cereal true so we were both top
five so we'll see it's gonna be a close
battle let's go to the phones I will say
this though top five and you had a
20-year Head Start
okay that's again that's generational
1964 that's been around what are you
gonna start giving your kids I'm gonna
give him Lucky Charms I had it you know
what I mean my guys they they came out
in 85 84. well yeah I think there are
much younger people on social media
versus older people 100 I don't think
like the 60 year olds are going to be on
here voting on this poll I don't know
what I'm saying is your 60 year olds had
a chance to get it out to more people if
I was if I was in the 60s and I had kids
that were 10 years old in the 60s and
Lucky Charms came out now you got kids
in the 60s eating Lucky Charms who were
given to their kids in the 80s were
given to their kids and you know what
I'm saying yeah I got what you're saying
I'm I'm trying to figure out if I
if I validate as an argument
oh it's definitely this definitely valid
as an argument it's definitely valid I
sound like a computer yeah
put it through you know see if it works
uh all right we're gonna go to the
phones uh which is just twitter.com yeah
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is a hug from you
Grandma Lucky Charms are a grope from
your weird smelly uncle they taste like
sadness well I don't know if Lucky
Charms are a grope from your uncle I
don't know if so so Cinnamon Toast
Crunch is is it reminds you of loving
family and Lucky Charms reminds you of
ancestral sexual assault I don't know
that's a stretch to me Lucky Charms more
like a lucky if you get anything nice in
your mouth cinnamon all the way this guy
doesn't know how to diss
ing a marshmallow on that spoon it's
kind of just I don't mind it it's cat
food nah because if you don't get a
marshmallow look that's just more
marshmallow in the next or it makes you
absence makes the heart grow fonder I do
want to say this look at this next one
y'all ever heard of chocolate Lucky
Charms that [__] is magically delicious
that's not even a vote for Lucky Charms
she's she's going away from even your
cereal well can I but you
on the poles
out of the whole skew okay okay next one
the milk tastes better after Cinnamon
Toast Crunch and feels less like eating
candy for breakfast than does Lucky
Charms okay the Soggy Lucky Charms can
take a walk Cinnamon Toast Crunch over
I'm getting hammered right now you're
getting killed Lucky Charms are for poor
people
Jesus Christ Thompson the same price at
the same price point 100 of Cinnamon
Toast Crunch is good only 30 percent of
Lucky Charms are good yeah but you can't
no because a hundred percent marshmallow
is not good
it's the balance that makes it work I
understand but the thing is you need the
marshmallow to make your cereal work
there's no other thing we're not trying
to you
because my thing has more mass you need
cinnamon to make yours isn't Toast
Crunch let me ask you this fun dip take
fun dip yeah you able to go are you cool
with not having the stick or is the
sticking element to you I love the stick
exactly I want this and you need them
both yeah you need it you need to give
it
of course that's in the title but
they're both ingredients why because my
ingredient has more mass you take
cinnamon out of yours Toast Crunch a
pound of Cinnamon Toast Crunch and a
pound of Lucky Charms are the same is my
point all right so the only way you can
legally buy Lucky Charms is with an EBT
card all right some sausage tits
sugary packing peanuts versus cinnamon I
am getting hammered thank you Jack
Bertelli magically delicious all day
babe could live without those
cannibalistic pieces of cardboard plus
gotta shout out Santino for landing
he can get that in a live action what
about panda bowls and almond milk I
don't know what that is
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is the greatest
cereal ever period boom thanks it's not
even close man should I have done
Frosted Flake it's time to admit that
Lucky Charms go back Lucky Charms is an
inferior product
wow scroll pimpy Lucky Charms are better
of the two
couple little marshmallows for oath
serial magic okay Coco Pops get I see ya
Cinnamon Toast Crunch is the champagne
of syrup Lucky Charms is the Mountain
Dew of cereal is only good because the
marshmallows the toast crunch puts on
like has this air of sophistication
about it I yeah I don't either I don't
think first of all these are all cost
the same amount you know what I mean
what are we really doing right you know
Lucky Charms is cheeros with styrofoam
marshmallows thrown in it Lucky Charms
taste like a headache I don't agree
there's nothing to not dude you're
getting pummeled I I'm getting it's
amazing time to start to finish perfect
crunch in the sweet cinnamon milk at the
end delightful and luck Lucky Charms
good for two bites and then mud water at
the end is disgusting well this guy our
guy here M Dog Duck one but don't make
me choose and has literally
uh someone with a gun to their head so I
guess it's a tough call for them
I have never met right underneath him I
have never met anyone that actually eats
the lucky charm cereal and not just the
marshmallows well you gotta meet more
people scroll down scroll up one second
we just passed it because it was funny
the only thing lucky about Lucky Charms
is the lucky green stool it produces all
right all right by the way you ready for
this yeah my daughter's birthday uh when
she was three or four I got a Star Wars
cake and I got black chocolate frosting
and it was the dopest cake ever yeah and
then the next day at school parents were
coming up to me like yo did you see your
kids poop everyone's poop was neon green
show me pics give me pics neon green wow
and I was like yeah
everywhere I go Sal uh have them on a
bracelet which is the only way I care
for them Cinnamon Toast Crunch is the
real party here oh wow is it no Cinnamon
Toast Crunch in the UK
but she voted for it anyway
flavored cardboard a lot of cardboard
all right
all right well I I clearly did not win
this the marshmallow uh so we go to this
segment called Humble Pie right now we
got a drum roll pimpy will roll in the
pie chart and pimpy's choosing uh we got
10 000 votes pimpy shoes and Cinnamon
Toast Crunch and here we go baby
oh man okay okay it's not 32 that's not
bad Cinnamon Toast Crunch wins handily
but according to the I saw two Lucky
Charms favorable posts in there I
thought I was gonna get like 90 10. yeah
Cinnamon Toast Crunch with the win
67.7 to 32.3 percent now I now wonder
what can beat Cinnamon Toast Crunch I
almost wanna like I I now wonder what
can beat that because Lucky Charms is
popular it is I don't think anything can
beat it telling you
think that'll beat
uh don't forget look at the Captain
Crunch berries Fruit Loops
Cheerios I mean I think it will take
Captain Crunch berries and just [__]
kick it to the side it won't even be in
the conversation I gotta know I gotta
know now and in Fruit Loops I think will
be in there but you saw like the top
sellers you had Cheerios you had Honey
Nut Cheerios those are parents right and
those are like they tried to sell us on
that Frosted Flakes again that's just
been around for so long and then you got
CTC and then you know what I'm saying
it's just wow I did not think it would
be like that I thought I was I thought
it was gonna be a that's good that was
good I'm surprised and I and now it's
making me wanna it's making me want to
do like a tournament or something a
Serial tournament maybe oh I mean I
think you could you could get you start
with 24 cereals and go head to head yeah
I think that's I think I think that'd be
fun to watch and I think special okay
gets ass handed to it in the first round
Special K that's crazy it's insane uh I
mean people use that's a desktop
computer
it totally is uh do you think we could
do tournaments live we're doing a live
taste buds on May 10th
um
you probably will hopefully see an
insert with all the specific details on
how and when to get the ticket we're
streaming live on May 10th we have an
insane battle lined up and tons of
surprise guests and a really really big
payoff uh with something else which you
can't mention it just now right now but
uh I was thinking can we do a live
tournament based on audience Applause
Just For Fun at the live because we're
we're most likely going to do the live
streaming with a live audience gotcha so
uh
we'll probably do a QR code I don't know
how you would measure the crowd audit
cloud with our ears oh okay
no
sweet 16 of cereals but you got to go
you gotta taste them you have to
literally taste them yeah but assuming
everyone's had them
right but there's a difference between
like tasting Lucky Charms up against
Honey Nut Cheerios and you might be like
you know what I Gotta Give it to Honey
Nut Cheerios right now because in the
moment because there's something I mean
there is a Honey Nut Cheerio is a great
remember you've talked about the
Simplicity of taste before right you
know what I mean that is a taste that's
simple and clean and pure like Italian
food you know okay all right well there
it is uh May 10th mark your calendars
we're streaming live that night it's
going to be a super sized bonus episode
a lot of fun surprises more details to
come if you haven't already seen
something at the top of the episode when
we did plugs Jay uh one more time on the
special where can they see you what what
do you want to plug all that stuff uh
well if this is before April 19th then
it's already it's coming out April 19th
on YouTube backslash Jay Larson comedy
it's called sounds like Bruce my second
self-produced special and if it's after
419 go over there to my YouTube and you
can watch it share it like it comment
please all of that helps and I
appreciate you having me on buddy this
is a lot of fun one of my favorite
people I love you to death the way we
close it is the winner says I still love
you to me I still love you Sal I love
you too thank you buddy taste buds they
come into the mic talking about the food
they hate talking about the food they
like two fools gonna fight but only one
food can be right taste buds man